I want to preface this I'm not drawing
any conclusions okay
I'm just making an observation
and the observation is that just weeks
before the massive vinyl chloride leak
and burn off that is currently poisoning
East Palestine Ohio and likely
compromising the air and water across a
much larger geographic region
the CDC changed its toxicology report on
vinyl chloride and its FAQ page
for the first time in 17 years
weeks before possibly as little as 11
days before but certainly it happened at
some point in the month before this this
accident so I've got here the
the toxicology report the FAQs from from
and here you just see a lot more
information in the 2006 one
How likely is vinyl chloride to cause
cancer you see a lot of specific
information about an increased risk of
liver brain lung cancer cancers of the
blood how can Vinyl chloride affect
children there's a whole paragraph about
that
has the federal government made
recommendations to protect human health
yes as the EPA requires that the amount
of vinyl chloride in drinking water not
exceeds 0.002 milligrams per liter of
water talks about how much in terms of
parts per million Can it can be in the
workplace it's pretty thorough and then
you go to the
the FAQ on vinyl chloride that just
dropped last month that the section on
how to protect children is totally gone
the section on cancer is a much
simplified that there's a lot less
detail the the section about how many
parts per million or milligrams per
liter that's all gone
so it's just a little this was January
this is just the what are what are the
odds all I'm saying is just the odds are
kind of
it's kind of weird and it isn't nearly
as weird as the fact that the whole
incident the whole train derailment
chemical spilling poisoned the town
incident was depicted in a movie that
came out last year was six eight months
ago called White Noise which was not
only filmed in the area in which the
actual incident would occur but even
included people from East Palestine as
extras in the movie One such extra an
East Palestine resident named Ben Ratner
has told reporters quote
the first half of the movie is all
almost exactly what's going on here
and I'm not making any accusations I'm
actually not okay I'm not coming to any
conclusions
even though the CDC and the public
authorities more broadly have completely
squandered their credibility in
particular over the last few years and
have lied to us on several occasions
you know I am not a conspiracy theorist
I'm really not
but I am a coincidence noticer
and it's weird I think I'm going to use
that just came to me when I was thinking
about these stories the White Noise
movie The toxicology report the FAQ from
the CDC I'm really not a conspiracy
theorist I always look for the least
complex answer for any sort of odd
phenomenon
but I definitely am a coincidence
noticer and it doesn't necessarily mean
that there is some secret shadowy group
of people that are doing all sorts of
Nefarious things at the very least
though there is no such thing as
coincidences you know modern Libs
believe that every strange no matter how
big the miracle is no matter how in your
face some kind of Miracle is they'll say
oh it's just random chance for
Christians though for people who are
traditionally religious there's no such
thing as coincidences because there's
Providence and there's an order to the
universe now
what's going on in this case in this
really bizarre
incident in East Palestine Ohio
is that just the broad order of the
universe is that just random chance or
something else I don't know I do know
that it's also really weird how the
authorities are downplaying this
incident had this been
a few weeks ago had you told me there's
going to be an environmental disaster
that happens
anywhere anywhere in the West
what's going to happen afterward I would
have said well you're going to get all
The Usual Suspects there John Kerry is
going to fly in and demand environmental
cleanup Saint Greta Saint Greta of the
Blessed sailboat she's going to come in
she's going to say how dare you trains
derail how there would be big protests
massive press conferences
none of that none of that has happened
you had no environmentalists have shown
up to protest
the authorities haven't shown up there's
no Joe Biden demanding stricter
environmental regulations his signature
legislative accomplishment last year was
passing a green bill right the climate
change bill which he initially told us
was an inflation reduction act but then
admitted almost immediately after it
passed now this is just about the
environment okay you care so much about
the environment where are you in East
Palestine how come nobody's talking
about this how come everyone wants to
play this down the the transportation
secretary Pete butterjudge took a little
break from his paternity leave his
Perpetual paternity leave to go on
television now what two weeks after the
incident and he went on television to
downplay the significance of the
derailment
look Rail City something that uh that
has evolved a lot over the years but
there's clearly more that needs to be
done because while this uh horrible
situation has gotten a particularly high
amount of attention there are roughly 1
000 cases a year of a train derailing
so it's no big deal actually guys I know
that uh there is this major derailment
where uh the all the water and and the
air around this this area has been
poisoned and I know that actually about
10 of the country gets its drinking
water from uh roughly around this region
but uh hey there's a lot of derailments
every year it's really not it's not a
big deal Move Along Move Along these are
not the droids you're looking for uh-huh
ah it seems like a big deal to me
and it seems like a big deal that the
authorities are saying this is not a big
deal that's really weird
maybe it's that Pete Buddha judge is
just trying to cya it could be maybe he
feels that he's totally exposed here and
he's a flop of a transportation
secretary a job that is essentially a
no-show job it's one of the least
important least notable jobs in the
government
people the judge got it as the Chinese
pointed out in their correct propaganda
yesterday he got it as a kind of vanity
political appointment to appease some of
the left-wing base and to check off some
politically correct boxes
but
you got to do something right and where
are the other people
Senator JD Vance new senator from Ohio
he's calling BS on the elected officials
and the EPA the EPA which is saying oh
no the water is totally safe to drink
this kind of thing happens all the time
Move Along move along well JD has a
challenge for the EPA administrator
you know it reminds me of that scene in
Aaron Brockovich where she puts the
water in front of him and says if you
think it's clean we brought this water
from uh you know the the community that
was affected uh look I I think that if
the EPA administrator wants to stand
here and tell people that the tap water
is safe by all means they should be
willing to drink it are you
uh no I just sold I told Tom I think
that uh if I was living here I would
drink the bottled water for now better
safe than sorry especially since it's
being provided for free that's the
guidance I would give it again you know
residents are going to make their own
decisions on this but my honest personal
advice is I'd be drinking the bottle of
water right now
I love the reporter's question maybe he
meant it in an innocent way or maybe it
was sort of a gotcha where JD van says
look if you really think this is all
fine EPA administrator come down here
right now and drink the water he says
well will you drink the water and JD
looks a little bit confused almost he
says
um no did you not hear what no I
wouldn't drink the water I think it's
poison and I I would drink the bottled
water especially when it's being
provided for free I don't believe the
EPA administrator and I doubt that the
EPA administrator believes the EPA
administrator
any does anybody seriously believe after
what a million gallons of of this or a
million pounds I sort of forget whatever
the measurement is of of this Vinyl
chloride to say nothing of the other
toxic chemicals that leaked at then were
set on fire turning to phosgene and
sulfuric or hydrochloric acid rather and
possibly sulfuric acid but certainly
hydrochloric acid you think that
two weeks after that the water is fine
the air is fine nobody believes that in
fact there's a resident of East
Palestine who just went out to show you
on video how not fine the water is so
this resident goes out to a little Creek
in the woods she gets a
little piece of wood and throws it into
the water so the water looks fine at
first but then the minute she disrupts
the water
with the wood then you see all the
chemicals bubble to the top
there's rainbow colors everywhere
you look down it's like
it's an oil slick
is it worse than an oil slick though
it's much more poisonous than an oil
slick
so it might it might look fine if you're
if you're an EPA administrator you're
going in you're testing the water and
you're just testing the water on top
maybe it looks fine maybe the point that
she's making is all the poison was down
there at the bottom so you throw a rock
in you throw a log in then all that
those chemicals rise up to the top
so sure we can all trust that the water
is safe in in East Palestine Ohio the
minute that Joe Biden or
the EPA administrator or Pete bootage
Edge or whoever go and drink it but none
of them are going to do that this
reminds me of in Indian elections
candidates who are running for office in
India will often go to Varanasi this
this holy city considered very holy in
India and that's where the Ganges is and
they'll go and they'll either wash
themselves in the water from the Ganges
they'll maybe they'll jump into the
water from the Ganges sometimes they'll
even drink some of the water from the
Ganges which is horrifying because
that's the river where people throw dead
bodies bodies that have been burnt on
along the side of the river or in some
cases even with human flesh on it and so
it's just teeming with bacteria and then
what happens the people get sick
well okay I give the politicians some
credit actually in their own religious
tradition they're willing to subject
themselves to that okay
leftist government administrators drink
that water in East Palestine drink that
water in East Palestine which could
affect water throughout a lot of the
country drink that make us all feel
better until they do I ain't buying it
the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss a go to
dailywear.com Knowles use code Knowles
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
foreign
[Music]